how you doing bud
good how are you
what's up
oh um i just wanted to make a comment
and well first off rich and roy both you
guys changed my life thank you man
appreciate it
um
in any case i wanted to comment that i
think uh islam is probably going to be
resistant to uh feminization
and uh three more surprise
yeah
hold out it'll definitely be the last
hold out yeah well it's it's essentially
uh my thinking on this is that the the
quran and the hadith and the seerah are
declared to be perfect and unchangeable
and that muhammad was the guy to be
emulated in all aspects
so any
any changes to it then uh
they brand you as an apostate
and you know if you're a catholic you
might get
excommunicated but if you're an apostate
in islam well the consequences are a
little more severe i'll tell you what
the problem is with that is that
boys want girls
yep and boys will do whatever it takes
to get girls
and girls are susceptible to these
narratives right i've already talked to
a lot of dudes there's a guy um i think
he goes by
[Music]
what's his name he's been on my show a
couple of times i think you've seen him
as well rolo it's like arab arab red
pill or something like that he's in uh
no no
um i think he's in syria but
i did a collab on his channel and took
some collins and i've had a few muslim
guys you know call into my shows like
over the years and
there there's a lot of plugged in beta
muslims out there and there's some women
that are being affected by the toxic
version of feminism that we see today
that's about supremacy and reach
um so is islam gonna gonna do well
against that better than some of the
other religions i think but i think
it'll be the last hold out to be honest
with you i think right right now
depending on the socioeconomic status of
that particular country
you will see
the
western influence of feminism and
gynocentrism uh by by incher by mile
find their way into those countries and
into those societies uh you can look at
uh girls in iran right now who go on
instagram and they they flaunt they take
off the hijab and they're all dancing
around they're risking really
persecution because if they find out
where they are they'll send the you know
the gestapo to come and round them up
but they're still doing that and they
get nothing but reward and uh
reinforcement from a larger global
sexual marketplace of course but like
from just a larger gynocentric world uh
you go girl if there is a uh abortion is
legalized in in ireland or in argentina
or wherever else it is it's not just
that country that's celebrating it it's
the whole world that is celebrating that
and so when i when i see these instances
of women in like say saudi arabia now
they can drive a car now they can own a
business it's just like it's just
incrementally kind of kind of working
its way in
depending on whether or not that country
can actually afford to have feminism in
there and have some way to to uh to
you know reconcile that with our
particular religion
if you look at somalia right now in a
very depressed third world country they
now have a feminist
government there and it is an islamic
country right now so there's incidences
all around the world where i can point
out and say there it is right there
there it is right there there and and i
i'm very hesitant to do that because uh
you know islamic very devout islam
muslim men don't want to be don't want
to have that presented to them but what
do you think the first thing is that
anyone says when i say oh look this
christian woman think or this christian
pastor over here is preaching feminism
from the pulpit this woman over here in
in the mosque is now trying to
to have a female imam the the mormon
church is now uh having feminists in
there what's the first thing do you
think a devout believer says when i
point out those instances
they say that's not real
x that's not a real muslim that's not a
real christian that's not a real jew
that's and it's i mentioned this from
the very beginning of the book is that i
can't fight
that no true scotsman uh argumentation
because all anyone falls back on as well
in the real religion if she was really a
christian then she wouldn't be doing
that but there it is black and white
over and over and over and over again
and so what i'm what i mean the point
that i make during this whole thing is
that by inch or by mile depending on the
faith christianity was the first to fall
judaism it's it's really judaism is
already mature linear to begin with so
judaism is sort of falling as well
islam slowly
slower than all the rest of the
abrahamic religions but after a while
give it give it one or two generations
and i think you're going to see it will
fundamentally change in the larger
respect
yeah
i have my doubts on that because you
know it's like i i was saying that
and the in the case of the no true
scotsman in islam that makes you an
apostate the penalty is is rather severe
and i i think they make accommodations
in muslim minority
countries but in muslim majority
countries i think it's a little bit
different yeah though and they will
until such time
as
the religion expands into larger
westernized countries and the influence
of gynocentrism
assimilates those religions
so yeah you could say well in somalia in
what is it boko haram you know central
africa wherever else yeah you might be
right where they can still get away with
that but in larger countries such as
like the united states the uk wherever
else where there's there's a state that
protects women from that
then you're going to see you're going to
see that religion change at least
fundamentally in that state so
what's the real religion when the
majority are more feminized and the
minority are the ones who are the
apostates right or the ones that are
enforcing that don't we have muslim
women in the u.s senate that are
feminists yes yeah talib uh what's going
to tell you rasheed and then in
it's just going to try to spread and go
as far as it can and leech off the host
it's it is what it is right but like
saying
yeah it's yeah it's going to be the last
battleground so what are they going to
say if it's if it's uh what's uh not to
leave but the other girl i can't
remember nate off top of my head but
like they'll just say she's just not a
real
you know muslim she's not a real one
they're using feminism in that case
because it's um uh they're in a minority
they're using feminism as the useful
idiots
you know like i would suggest that you
know while they're in the majority then
they're going to use feminism or
anything else to advance their cause but
probably a more accurate model would be
is if you look at lebanon
which you know formerly was christian
and now is muslim major majority when
they get when the
they're in the majority then the rules
change
and you know you get locked down or you
know uh
stricter rules right yeah
return to the unchanging book but anyway
that's just
just my take on it cool man great
thoughts thanks
all right um let's
well we're at the 90 well we're playing
omar that's who it is
yeah that's it yeah go ask abu american
whether he thinks ilan omar is a real
muslim
look at a really good answer from them
you